we've talked a lot of this show we're
going to talk a lot more about the
growth of the power of big tech
companies and how they are now a far
bigger threat to your civil liberties
than the federal government ever was now
the head of a social media network says
that Google is censoring his company how
bill Ottman is the co-creator of mine
comedy joins us in the studio tonight
bill thanks for coming on thanks for
having go Google trying to censor your
company how so we got banned from their
advertising platform probably caught up
in their out-of-control algorithms
yes basically blanket ban companies
based on certain keywords with no real
rational perspective I'm not overstating
it when I say if you're banned from
Google's ad platform I mean that that
can be death for a company it can it's
actually killed tons of companies and
content creators on YouTube who are D
monetized it's it's pretty serious so
they have the power to just snuff out a
young company why did they do this to
you do you think you do something wrong
probably some keyword they got caught up
in their algorithms but it's actually a
symptom of a bigger problem of
censorship algorithm manipulation
happening on all of the major social
networks and so we're actually building
our own ad network to battle this and
this can be complete transparent on the
blockchain so that everyone can see
what's happening with our system where
it's completely open source
anyone can inspect it peer review it so
this is how things have to be that can't
be proprietary they can't and one thing
I think the news consuming public
doesn't understand is that almost all
news you read online is controlled by
Google and Facebook because they control
what 90% of the ads so they're in charge
they own all the new sources in effect
and when you go to people's websites who
hosts Google ads Google is actually
spying on you through those websites so
by putting Google ads in your website
you're actually becoming an agent of
Google so that's why we need transparent
more freedom based ad platforms to
emerge which don't spy on people by
default so you're challenging one of the
most complete monopolies in American
life why would they let you do that well
I was not about them letting us do that
it's I mean decentralization open-source
blockchain
transparent social networks are emerging
and there's really nothing they can do
about it hopefully they will transform
that's what you can hope so you think
that they have they have this power the
federal government has done nothing
about it they have a monopoly over
basically over all digital information
and the federal government refuses to
rein it in for whatever reason you think
you can provide an alternative to that
you can free up the system from their
control yeah I mean it's it's happening
free open-source decentralized networks
are are arising what's it going to be
called I mean it's gonna be a network of
networks the next big network probably
is not going to be a centralized site
it's going to be a multitude of networks
interoperating so that it actually can't
get censored hmm so you think that this
will radically disempower Google and
Facebook I think that this movement will
for sure yeah yeah hired bodyguards
gonna build it that's what just kidding
but but Godspeed and we'll definitely be
rooting for you that would be
transformative I think in ways that
people don't even fully understand but
we're definitely on your side Thanks
thanks sorry